j'étais toujours intéressé par les ché
c'est sûr que mes propres cheveux et
elle a raison si mon élan c'est mon
héritage on va dire selon un rapport de
nuancer naissance le pouvoir d'achat des
afro-américains dépassera bientôt les
1300 milliards de dollars aux états unis
pourtant seule une infime portion de ce
montant est dépensé dans des commerces
détenus par des personnes noires
ni cheveux font une super grand aspect
au sens une super grands aspects de mon
identité je crois ça fait toujours
c'était toujours un problème ou un
challenge grandi en autriche comme on
dit avec mes cheveux et immigré au
canada j'ai réalisé en fait même ici il
n'avait rien qui a comblé mon besoin
j'ai réalisé que je suis pas seul dans
cette situation c'est là où j'ai vu un
super grand niche en fait besoin sur le
marché surtout pour la nouvelle
génération pour toutes les petites
filles qui sont là qui savent pas
comment gérer leurs cheveux naturels les
cheveux par des tout contre histoire
noire à ça veut dire tu peux vraiment
lire sur les cheveux am nos souffrances
la façon comment on était esclave la
façon qu'ont été colonisés mais
naturellement si l'histoire avant la
story d'avant ça veut dire à notre
statut dans la société en afrique
est-ce que quelle position j'ai eues
dans la position dans leur communauté
est-ce que gt gt une presse que j'étais
quelqu'un qui avait un qui était une
juge est ce que j'étais quelqu'un qui
était responsable pour la communication
tout ça en fait ça c'est réfléchi dans
les styles de chevaux différents et
c'est vraiment intéressant de regarder
le parcours d'une histoire de noir en
fait à travers les cheveux tu vas voir
que c'est hyper mais il perd luc hees
est vraiment csu crohn en fait et
aujourd'hui on a le choix de de nous
représenter comme on veut et d'avoir ce
pouvoir aujourd'hui d'être là de parler
de cheveux naturels de parler d'avoir
une boutique un salon qui est seulement
exclusivement dédié aux cheveux naturels
fait beaucoup dire aussi sur notre
position aujourd'hui dans la société
encourager la classe moyenne noire
à dépenser une plus grande part de ses
revenus dans sa communauté afin de
stimuler son économie
écrire l'emploi a vraiment une équipe
formidable et les gens qui sont qui
s'assume qui s'assume naturellement et
qui a donné l'inspiration ont fait
assumer toi même ça c'est hyper
important pour toutes nos clients et
c'est important que sept lieues du
safety unit lieu secure en fait tic c'st
pour nous aussi on pense au marché du
cheveu qui fait 3 points 2 6 milliards $
l'amérique du nord
on parle pas du petit chiffre on parle
vraiment d'une économie qui est
grandiose qui est extraordinaire et ça
fait une magnifique vraiment une grande
différence
ou est-ce que tu achètes et comment tu
achètes est-ce que tu soutiens la
communauté est ce que tu soutiens une
autre famille noire une femme noire ou
est-ce que tu as soutient une hyper
grande industrie les produits que tu
voies aériennes ils sont faites
exclusivement pour les cheveux bouclés
pour les cheveux naturels et les locks
et pas seulement qu'ils sont naturelles
mais on s'y fait par les familles noires
pas les femmes noires
ça veut dire dès que tu achète quelque
chose en fait du soutien avec ton
dollars une autre interprète noir tu
vraiment optimiste je crois qu'il ya un
mouvement en fait qui est en train de
s'écrire
de se conscientiser sur la richesse noir
sur notre a un impact sur la société en
général et sur quelle signification
nous avons en fait sur la société du
canada mais naturellement aussi dans la
diaspora et ça c'est quelque chose pour
avoir
[Musique]